大家好，欢迎来到切片不计划的第一期，我是切切。
我现在正坐在米兰的房间里面，而现在我的身后是两个摊开的巨大的行李箱，因为我马上就要去加纳电影节了。
而我今年下半年的规划就是从米兰搬到巴黎去，所以好像你两个行李箱就一直摊在那里，等待下一次要上路的时候。
我其实从来没有想过说我的人生会是现在种状态，当然小时候肯定是很希望以后能够环游世界一直在路上，但那个时候你好像不会想到。
当你的人生一直处在流动状态的时候，原来是这种行李箱一直摊在房间里，你每次经过的时候都要用你的双脚去跨过那个行李箱。
然后要么是准备搬家，要么是正在打包的这种状态，你每天要处理非常多细碎的事情，而这种状态可能有时候甚至会让你觉得艳烦。
我觉得这种生活，它说好听点是一种有目状态，但说难听点，用我妈妈的话来说就是你为什么要把你的人生过得这么折腾啊？
而在这种状态中要去录一期播客，其实我心里是很坠坠不安的。
我也思考了很久究竟第一期要录什么，甚至之前本来已经花了几天录了一期，但又觉得不对，推倒重来了。
但当我每次在这个房间里面经过要跨过那些行李箱的时候，我就会被这种又烦躁，但是又有点兴奋，因为要上路的那种感觉所包围。
所以我刚刚就在想说，哎，那要不第一期我就干脆录一下这些年武班家的经历吧？
因为我数了数啊，从23年到现在，从一开始的北京，到后来的青麦，佛罗伦萨，米兰，再到后面可能要去巴黎，我居然搬了超过十字架，非常的夸张啊？
而且你会发现好像每次的搬家，它都代表这个人生新的阶段，而且好像在这个过程中你的价值观会不断的发生转变。
你对每一个城市还有每一个国家和它的民族文化都会产生一种非常深的认知上的更迭。
就像我对意大利，可能我对它从充满滤进到滤进破碎，再到后来可能能以一种更客观的心态去看待它。
这中间我觉得是经历了非常多困难和实际的经验才促成的。
所以我觉得我可以跟大家分享的也不只是搬家的经历，而是每次搬家它都为每一个阶段的我和我对这个国家文化的认知带来了什么变化。
不过在开始讲这些故事之前，我也想先和正在听这期播客的大家重新认识一下。
可能听到切遍不计划这个名字，有一些熟悉我的老观众会笑出声。
因为很多人知道我可能都是通过B站或者小红书看到了我的频道，切遍计划。
这是一个我大概做了6年的影视美学频道，也通过这个频道认识到了很多很多的观众和我现在的好朋友。
而我觉得好像大家一直熟悉的都是视频里面的那个接接。
就好像总是思维整密然后结构精巧，并且能提供给大家一些所谓独特一点的视角吧？
但很多时候我都会觉得那样的一个接接是一种幻觉。
因为可能大家没有看到的是我在电脑面前无数次抓着脑塞的样子。
包括我在剪辑的时候会无数次的怀疑自己，这期视频应不应该发，它真的做的够好吗？
它真的值得吗？那种为了一起好视频而把自己逼到枯竭的状态，是我那几年切切实实的感受。
我觉得自己是一个非常标准的这一人，所以很多时候我都会痛苦于自己的计划和高标准。
所以当我想到要做一期播客的时候，我的第一个念头其实是压力。
我会觉得好像我必须做出一些好的东西来，才可以把它送到大家面前。
但如果抱着这样的心态，就怎么也录不出来。
甚至包括这个播客的名字我都想了很久。
然后就在我一直纠结的时候，我一个朋友就问我说，能不能不要计划，想到什么就说什么？
然后我们突然就想说，那这期播客的名字，怎么就不可以叫切片补计划呢？
怎么就不能让它成为一个比较自然流淌的东西，尝试着轻松一点去跟大家分享我这几年的一些感受、体验和变化。
它可以是这几年我在欧洲的一些文化观察，也可以是我最近看的书和电影，或者只是跟大家分享我生活中的一地鸡毛。
所以它可能不会有像切片计划那样严密的逻辑和美学的享受啊？
但我觉得可能在这里，你可以看到一个更加真实的我，没有被修减掉太多的毛变。
当然就是很多口误，我应该还是会悄悄把它减掉的。
但我希望能够通过这期播客，找到一种更加轻松表达的状态，也能跟大家一起去度过一些无聊所随的时间。
不知道说起搬家，大家脑海中闪过的第一个画面是什么？
但在我脑海中印象最深刻的那个画面，其实是小的时候，我们家经历过非常多的搬家。
因为我家是开塑料家工厂，塑料玩具厂的。
但你说是工厂，它其实就是朝山地区非常多的那种手工小桌坊。
你其实一年到头厂里不过就是几个人，然后坑吃坑吃的在那里，装倒塑料。
而那个时候我的家境并不是很好，所以我们没有能力去买下一块地，开个自己的工厂，就只能不断的租工厂。
甚至家和工厂是混合在一起的，我从小就跟着爸妈一起住在工厂里面。
而种租来的生活是非常不稳定的，大概每隔两三年，我就会和我家里和厂里所有的东西。
被一起打包放在一个三轮车上，然后迁移到下一个厂和下一个家里面。
我记得我小的时候也是没有自己的房间这个概念的，小的时候是跟爸爸妈妈和弟弟住在一起。
到后来我第一次有记房间的概念是，当时在厂里，然后有一片地区被划出来当做我们每个人的卧室。
虽然它其实就是在几个房间的中间加了一块木板，而上面都还是通着的，你并不拥有一个完全独立的数字的空间。
但那个时候我拥有了一张属于自己的桌子，我可以开始摆上我的书，我的小书包。
而不是像之前一样坐在我爸妈用来记账的那个桌子上，被工厂的噪音包围着去写我的作业。
我开始拥有了一个相对安静而独立的空间。
但后来其实无非就是跟大家一样，小声出，出声高，然后再到大雪。
即使后来从北市大宿舍搬出来住到了朝阳区的一个租来的小公寓里。
我觉得那也是一种学生状态的延续，甚至我当时的室友就是我研究生的室友。
而我在心理意义上的第一次搬家，是我决定离开北京的时候。
为什么选择离开北京呢？我其实在之前的视频里面有跟大家分享过。
那段时间我觉得自己的人生好像陷入了像一部电影叫土波属之日那种状态。
每天好像都是一个无尽的循环。
一睁眼就是想选题，想无限多的选题，然后比较哪一个值得做。
选定之后就开始了无尽的写稿，每一本最少都会写三到四遍。
而这个过程中是无数次的推翻重来。
之前有人问过我说一个视频大概要做多久啊？
其实这是不定的，可能一期快的稿子，我才思如全用。
比如说当时做不正经作家余华的那期，当时还没有多少人做余华的视频。
但因为我的余华的作品还比较熟悉，所以只花了一个下午就写出来了。
然后那天晚上回去就开始录音，隔天剪了一天的剪辑，大概两天左右就发布了。
但也有像王家卫或者美人谱戏这些女演员的专题。
我可能前期收集资料，包括把她所有的作品都看完。
就需要花一周甚至小半个月的时间，然后再开始写稿。
通常写稿这一部完成之后，你就发现你已经筋疲力尽了。
而那个时候我录音也是嗑嗑巴巴的，可能大家听到一期二十分钟的视频。
我可能要整整录上三四个小时，但录完音之后你才开始最辛苦的环节剪辑。
我的第一个剪辑视频，其实就是我发布的第一期视频。
所以相当于我是在做切片计划的这个过程中，不断的去开始学习剪辑，这件事的。
也是在这个学习的过程中，不断的越来越精进，越来越好。
每次剪完一期视频我都会觉得好像记得元气被耗干了。
但还没有完，你要开始想标题，要开始设计封面。
当时我还没有封面的设计师，所以基本上从零到一都是我自己来的。
还有一个帮我很多的朋友会帮我一起出某花策。
但真的那个刚起步的阶段就相当于一种微型的创业，什么琐碎的事情都需要你自己来。
你每天会被上百个甚至上千个念头围绕着，你要不断的去做出决定。
而这样的生活到二三年我几乎整整坚持了四年。
前两三年我都还在北师大上学，所以你除了做视频之外还有非常多的事可以去做。
但二三年我毕业之后搬到了北京朝阳区的一个租来的小公寓里面。
那时候你会发现你的生活好像就只剩下一件事情，做视频。
所以我才会说很像土布鼠之日，因为你就好像陷入了一个时间循环里面。
每一天都变成了同一天。
很多时候啊，我觉得如果你是为别人工作，你有很多的借口可以去埋怨，可以去说这不是你想做的。
但当你选择了当一个自由职业者，选择为自己工作时。
你就也必须为自己所选择的生活负权责，你甚至很难去抱怨。
而是什么样的念头促使我要离开北京呢？
是我记得二三年三月的时候吧，我连着做了两三个非常重的视频。
那段时间我开始发现自己时常有一种窒息的感觉，就是生理意义上的。
有点喘不过气，然后也吃不下饭。
后来我去医院检查发现是胃酸反流。
但医生跟我说，胃其实是一种情绪性的器官。
如果你一直紧张焦虑的话，你的胃就会有很大的反应。
几乎就是你的心理超负荷之后，你的身体启动的一种应激和保护机制。
那是我第一次非常强烈的意识到，我当时的工作状态是不健康的。
但就是在那样的情绪状态下，我发现我竟然在我的生活里面。
找不到任何一种可以让我的情绪变得更缓和的方式。
在做完视频精疲力尽之后，我很想要下楼去散步。
但那时候我发现我竟然不知道可以去哪里。
不知道大家会不会有跟我一样的感受就是。
当你走下楼，你会发现每一条路你都走过了。
每一条路的镜头是什么，你都清清楚楚的知道。
无非就是便利店、地铁口，还有连锁的咖啡店。
但是好像没有任何一条路会通向意外。
而那个时候的我，其实就很厌烦那种感觉吧？
甚至有的时候我会想要找朋友。
但是我会发现在弱大的北京城里面。
我想去找一个朋友，我会需要做一个半小时的地铁。
才能够找到他，甚至他也不一定有空，他可能在加班。
所以那时候我发现，如果我继续待在这里。
我可能真的很难在这个城市集取到很多的养分。
虽然我始终对北京有一种很亲切的感觉。
而且现在回想起来，我觉得23年是一个。
我的人生里面发生了很多变故，很多关系崩塌。
然后又开始重建了一年。
那个时候我处于一种非常迫切的。
想要逃离原本生活的那种状态。
所以那个时候我就蒙发了一个念头啊？
为什么我要把记困在这里呢？
我不是自由职业者吗？
为什么我不能发挥这种自由的便利。
去一个我更想生活的城市呢？
我当时脑子里蹦出来的第一个地方，就是欧洲。
因为我从小其实一直有想出国留学的想法。
但因为当时经济条件不支持嘛？
即使后来长大了，也攒到了一点点的积蓄。
但我知道这些钱对于在欧洲生活是悲水车薪的。
但我心里还是会有这样的念头。
我希望在我人生的某个阶段，我能去到欧洲。
去获取不一样的文化视角和生活的体验。
所以这个就像一个种子一样，一直住扎在我的心里。
我当时有两个特别想去的地方，一个是意大利。
另一个就是巴黎
但当时为什么没有选择巴黎。
我觉得首先是因为它比较贵。
另一个是我在巴黎完全没有认识的朋友。
但我当时在意大利有一个认识的朋友。
而在这个过程中他帮助了我很多。
他当时帮我算了一笔账，让我发现说。
哦，原来去欧洲留学，尤其是去意大利这样的国家。
他或许并不需要非常昂贵的花俏。
如果你不那么大手大脚，节约这点用。
其实他一年的生活成本有可能跟你在北上广障的大城市。
正常生活的费用差不多吧？
这两位朋友当时甚至帮我联系了佛罗伦萨的语言学校。
这笔账还有这种朋友的帮助支持。
让我发现说，哦，原来去到那个地方并不是不可能实现的。
我记得那大概是4月还是5月的某一天吧？
当时我在北京东四华一个叫1900的咖啡馆里面走出来。
然后我看到了天边的晚霞。
当时我有一种如是重负的感觉。
我想着说，哇，原来卸下身上的重负。
去奔向一种自由的未知的生活。
是这样一种感觉啊？
在做了这个决定之后，我就退掉了北京的房子。
然后在准备签证料理切的这个过程中，其实还有好几个月嘛？
我就和另外两位一样也是自由职业的朋友，第一次出了国。
我们选了泰国青麦这样一个生活成本比较低。
同时各方面又比较便利的城市。
进行了一次为期一个月的履居生活的尝试。
我当时觉得这可以为我后面去欧洲做一次预演。
而现在想来，那个夏天也是我迈向一个更大世界的第一步。
所以那个暑假，我就和我的这两位朋友在青麦订了一个房子。
我到现在都记得那个在宁麦路市中心的房子。
它是一个两层的小独动。
那里的吃的、交通。
包括各种生活成本其实都会比北京低很多。
相当于我们可以用更低的成本去履居一个月。
当时的行李箱里面除了必要的衣物和各种生活用品。
我记得我装了很多工作的东西。
包括我录音的话筒，它其实很重啊？
但是我必须要带着它，然后我的电脑，我的各种的设备。
我就记得当什么三个人，每天白天早晨就去买杯咖啡，吃完早餐。
然后就坑吃坑吃的在那个房子里面工作一整天。
然后三个电脑一起摆在长桌前面，劈力啪啦地敲着字。
每天结束都感觉啊，今天又完成了好多好多的工作。
到晚上气温降下来，我们就会去宁麦路去古城。
或者去青麦大学附近散步吃晚餐，探索青麦各个好玩的地方。
我还记得当时我们经常去按摩，因为白天都会工作的特别累。
但青麦按摩的价格又非常便宜。
我感觉一个月下来，我们几乎把青麦那些能玩的能吃的，还有能按的都做过了。
一个月结束之后，我的这两位朋友就回国了。
但我当时想继续在青麦住一段时间，所以我就找到了一个木头房子。
我还记得我当时拍了一张图片是，这个小木屋里面有一个木头的桌子。
上面放着我的电脑和录音设备，而旁边有个窗，窗外就是一种片的草坪和树木。
我从那个视角拍了那张照片之后，到现在它都是我朋友圈唯一的一个置顶。
因为可能我一直都觉得，如果我的心也需要住一个房子的话，那我就会选择住张的一个房子。
一个这么宁静又充满阳光，适合创作的木头房子。
很好笑的就是，当时我们每天都会把电脑搬去桌子外面的一个走廊，上面去写东西或者剪辑。
我当时泰国房东是个很渴爱的老太太，她就笑着说，怎么会有人来到泰国每天都在工作啊？
怎么会有这么多的工作可以做？
到后来我推荐了那个民宿之后，有其他的朋友去住了，然后她问房东说，她还记不记得我。
我房东说，我当然记得啊，就是那个每天都在工作的令。
我觉得真的非常好笑，其实在她看来可能是个很紧繃的一直在工作的年轻人。
但是她可能不知道，那个是我第一次拥抱自由和经营的经历。
我会发现，原来在一个完全不一样的地方，我也能这么好好的工作和生活。
然后被如此多的养分和新鲜感冲营着，感觉摸索到了世界的另一条路径。
那是我第一次感受到，原来人不背负着这么多东西，也是可以活下去的。
原来家也不一定是一个固定的居所，你可以只是一个行李箱做装下所有的东西。
我之前其实也看过很多类似于这种出走题材的电影，比如说吃饭祈祷恋爱，或者托斯卡纳燕阳下。
然后可能都是主角经历了个人生的非常大的转变，然后她决定离开自己生活的地方，去到一个完全不一样的地方。
但我觉得我的第一次打个银号的出走，其实并没有那么的戏句话，它其实是一种日常。
我每天在那个木头房子里面早起，冲一杯咖啡，然后早上六七点的时候，在那个撒满阳光的长廊，那个座椅上面，摊开我的书，看一会儿然后开始工作。
每天仗循环往复，但它让我体会到了一种从未有过的轻盈和自在感。
现在回想起来，青麦这次经历其实很像游戏里那种新手村的经验，你会觉得它生活成本很低，难度系数也相对低。
因为都是亚洲城市，其实吃的东西，语言，包括整个的生活状态，都是更相近的，不会有那么多的差距。
我还记得我当时去青麦，除了刚说的那些必要的工作工具之外，我还带了一本书，叫世界的镜头。
然后里面有一张就是曼谷，他提到说Tylen这个词，他的词根的意思其实是自由之地。
我想这就是那两个月的青麦之旅给我的感觉，一种自由轻盈的奔向新世界的感觉。
但在那里住了两个月之后，我也开始发现，这确实是一个能让我喘气的地方，但它可能不是一个能让我长期生活的地方。
因为它并没有那么多文化的养分，和并没有那么多元的那种人群的流动和交流。
如果我想要更多的体验感受，甚至是想要文化的冲击，那么它在无形中，其实反而让我更坚定了我应该去往欧洲的这个念头。
而在那年的11月，我的签证下来了，所以在23年的12月，我就拿着自己那几年攒下来的积蓄，把自己送到了弗洛伦萨。
你如果让我用现在的视角去回看？我会想说，我当时之所以能出发，完全是因为无知。
因为说实话，我当时几乎对欧洲生活毫无概念，我从来没有去过欧洲，青麦就是我的第一次出国。
我也不会说意大利语，我不知道在意大利租房有多难，我也不知道搬一个居留居然要折腾那么久。
我不会知道我会在这一年经历崴脚，搬那么多自家，那些非常让我崩溃的事情。
我什么都不知道，但正是因为我什么都不知道，我才敢做这个决定。
我后来想，这大概就是一种所谓的出生流毒不怕虎的心态，你不是因为勇敢才决定出发的，你完全是因为无知。
但很多时候，你回看人生中那些重要的决定，可能就需要那么一点点的无知。
如果你什么都知道，你大概率就不会选择去了。
我记得当时特别好笑，我妈妈给了我一个小红包，你们知道里面是什么吗？是一小撮土。
然后我妈说，让我去了佛罗伦萨之后，然后加一点点水，然后把这个土放到佛罗伦萨的土地上。
跟他们那边的水土交融在一起，然后就说明，我这个外来的人要来加入你们的土地了。
你要让我水土相融一下，让我顺顺利利平平安安的度过这几年。
我现在想起这个洗俗都觉得非常有意思，在潮汕就是会有非常多，这种你觉得很莫名其妙，但是又很合理的洗俗。
不知道大家第一次出远门的时候，你们的父母会不会给你准备一些乱七八糟的东西。
但我觉得都饱含着他们的心意，因为他们也不知道远方是什么样的。
所以他们只能用这小撮土，然后想象你在远方的土地上，把它倒在花瓶上的样子。
用这种最切切实实的东西来告诉你，他们希望你一切都好吧？
我到现在还记得我下飞机的那一刻，我当时坐了12个小时的飞机。
那是我第一次经历长途飞行，但我好像一点都不疲惫，我整个人是一种非常惊奇的状态。
你们知道那种感觉吗？就不只是新鲜，而是所有的感官都被你打开了，你看什么都觉得。
原来是这样啊，原来那些我在语文课本、历史课本上看到的、想象的东西，原来就是这样的呀？
那是我第一次看见佛罗伦萨，也是我第一次看见欧洲。
我觉得，头两周我几乎都是在这种飘着的、惊奇的状态中渡过的。
我去咖啡店点一杯esplaso我都觉得很有趣，会努力要区分esplaso， cappuccino，和macchietto之间的区别。
然后我当时那个语言学校，是在佛罗伦萨老城区移动非常古老的建筑力。
你走到教室里面一抬头，天花板上就是古老的壁画。
那时候我坐在那间教室里，学着意大利语，心里有一种非常不真实的感觉。
小时候我在语文课本上看到威尼斯小庭这篇文章，我当时就心想，有一天我一定会来到这里。
而现在我竟然就真真切切地坐在这里，在这个古老的教室里，学着一种我从来不知道应该怎么说的语言。
而我觉得佛罗伦萨也的确不愧对文艺复兴古城的这样一个称号。
我一直觉得由来意大利最好的方式就是你不要做任何的攻略。
当然这是一种很奢侈的做法了，就是你在那里生活更长一段时间。
然后你每天出门，转角就会遇到惊喜。
就像在佛罗伦萨，我还记得有一天我放学了。
我想着说现在才下午5点钟，我要去随便哪个教堂里面逛逛。
然后就走到了一个修道院门口，买了一张票进去。
当我走到那个阶梯的镜头，无网上抬头，发现阶梯的镜头，就是那幅著名的天使报喜。
我才发现原来这就是著名的圣马可修道院，是陈丹卿在举步里面提到的一定要去一次的那个修道院。
这就是佛罗伦萨给我的感觉。
每一个转角，每一个石头路上，它都有它的古老的印记和历史和故事。
你去到米开朗级楼上面复看整个佛罗伦萨，你会发现你此刻看到的景观就跟400年前的人们看到的一模一样。
我还记得我当时心想，我真的来对了。
但是在一个月之后，在2023年最后一天的那个跨年夜，一切都开始改变了。
在刚过零点，烟花阵放的瞬间，我崴脚了。
关于这件事的具体过程，我当时怎么崴到脚，又怎么慢慢恢复。
我之前在切片计划那期，欧洲流量三个月后，我忽然看懂了所有的电影里，讲得比较多。
感兴趣的朋友可以去回看一下。
但今天我站在一个两年后的视角去回看这件事，还蛮奇妙的。
因为那个时候你会意识到，原来一个26岁的成年人，也可以在一夜之间被打回一种像婴儿一样的状态。
当时因为任代的严重撕裂，我有整整两个多月不太能走路。
当时我刚好住在朋友家，幸好有他们一直在照顾我。
不然我觉得我可能会陷入一种更加崩溃和狼狈的境地。
但无论是生理还是心理上的，其实有很多的困难，你都必须自己学着一点点去克服。
甚至那个时候因为脚受伤，连走路这样轻而易举的事情，它都变得无比艰难。
你甚至要重新学习。
你要学着把重心放在哪只脚上，怎么样一拳一拐的下楼梯。
然后怎么在佛罗伦萨那种坑坑挖挖，非常容易崴脚的路上，让自己不要再摔倒，不要再崴脚。
而因为刚刚出来渣道，我也不太会说一大粒语。
所以我连我的脚很痛这样的话，我都不能够完整的说出来，只能靠笔划和猜测。
你要从最简单的刷牙、洗澡、吃饭账的词语开始学习。
就像回归婴儿状态重新开始牙牙学语。
而且甚至我连去邮局寄一个包裹这样简单的在国内可能10分钟就能做好的事情，都是要重新学习。
那种感觉真的非常奇怪。
我明明已经活了26年了，我之前以为我是知道怎么生活的。
可是怎么换了一个国家之后，你就发现你自己什么都不会了，你回到了零。
但现在回过头看，你又会觉得重婴儿状态像一种礼物。
因为它会让你重新学习，怎么央用一双新的眼睛去重新看这个世界。
当时每一天我都需要非常专注看脚下的路。
也是在那个时候我才发现，原来佛罗伦萨和很多意大利的城市。
它脚下那些路上有很多像名牌一样的东西。
它可能是为了纪念二战中牺牲的犹太人，或者是纪念各式各样的名人。
因为不会说话，所以你是要听。
你就会仔细去听意大利语的发音，和每个人他说话时那种不一样的语气。
你甚至要集中注意力去听，油脂的大爷。
他这嗦一嗦尖是什么意思啊，这件事究竟是能办还是不能办呢？
这其实是一种很累的状态啊，我觉得已经不是生活了，就是在生存。
但是你后来回想你会觉得，人这一辈子又有几次能够被打回音儿状态重新学习。
重新看见一切呢？
但在脚伤开始恢复之后，我就开始了最大的这个难关，找房。
可以跟大家说一下背景啊，就是为什么佛罗伦萨找房这么难。
首先它是一个小镇，它的面积和房源都非常有限。
但刚好，它又是一个世界知名的旅游重镇。
所以每年来佛罗伦萨的一个客量是惊人的，几乎没有淡季啊？
但这里的当地居民他谋生的手段又非常有限，所以就决定了。
如果你有一个房子，那么你最好的用来谋生的手段。
就是把它当成一个短租的民宿租出去。
这会比你常租给别人的收入多的多。
而且疫情之后，佛罗伦萨房价也是涨溜涨。
可能整个欧洲都是这样的，但佛罗伦萨这种旅游重地尤其。
这也就意味着，如果你要租到一个好的房子，你必须不断的抬高你的租房成本。
但很多时候，即使你的预算抬到了800欧1000欧。
也就是人民币6、7000、8、9000的这个价格，你可能依旧租不到好的房子。
因为佛罗伦萨实在是太破了。
他的美妙在于他的古老，但是他糟糕的地方也在于他的古老。
他那些破旧的路导致你会非常非常容易崴脚。
我已经有不瞎五个朋友，在佛罗伦萨在罗马崴过脚了。
并且由于大家都想保持这种古老，所以很多的房子内部都是非常非常之沉旧。
甚至有非常多的暗病的。
所以在佛罗伦萨就有一个租房的不可能三角，好房子便宜的价格和你能租到。
你做多只能选其中两个，运气不好的话一个都选不上。
我又是一个对房子要求特别高的人，因为我是自由职业者。
我每天可能24小时都在房间里面工作和生活。
一个糟糕的房子对我来说可能不只是不舒服，是直接没有办法工作。
所以那一年，找房就成了我的噩梦。
我大概贴着我的两个大行李箱和一个小行李箱，搬了超过八次家。
这期间我一直在不同的Airbnb和短租的房子里面周转。
就像我在之前的视频里面说到过的，这中间我遇到了真的很棒很棒的人。
像是Francesca和Kala奶奶，他们一开始都是我的房东。
但在我住进去的那些日子里面，我们有了很深很深的精神共鸣和交流。
说来很神奇啊，我们一开始聊起来其实都是因为电影。
因为Francesca和他两个女儿都特别喜欢看电影。
而很意外的我们的电影品味和共同语言卷如此之多。
我到现在都觉得好奇妙啊？
居然就在那个雨天我托着我的三个行李箱走进这个挂满了女性肖像的房子里。
我就遇到了一个在精神上与我如此同频的人。
而且很奇妙的，可能就是因为我们之间有20多岁的那灵茶。
我们反而能更了解彼此。
因为说实话，这一代的意大利的年轻女孩。
他们在性别意识上或者生活的优惑程度上都比我们好很多了。
但反而是上一代的意大利女性。
她可能跟我们这一代人面对的困难和处境是更类似的。
所以交流起来好像心会靠得更近一点点。
而且我觉得很多的意大利女性。
他们真的是有一种非常强悍的生命力。
和非常强大的母性的包容和关怀。
就像还有明天里的那个妈妈一样。
然后包括凯莱奶奶，我们的相遇也是非常的神奇。
一开始我也是租了她的房子。
但每天晚上奶奶都会做饭，我们会一起吃饭。
在这个期间我就吃到了她做的无数的托斯卡纳菜。
说实话，我是一个潮汕人。
所以我对食物的要求还是比较高的。
但奶奶做的那些托斯卡纳菜真的是比我在很多餐馆吃到的还要好吃。
我觉得这可能也间接导致了我后来不太喜欢吃意大利菜的原因。
就觉得都没有奶奶做的好吃。
我之前有专门做过一个视频讲我和奶奶之间的故事。
我觉得她真的是一个到这么大年纪，70岁了。
还保持着非常充沛好奇心。
和对其他民族，其他文化的人的关怀的一位老人。
我到现在都记得她当时说她很喜欢看。
我的解放日子就是一部韩剧。
所以她对东亚的年轻人那种状态。
我跟她说内卷啊，或者是东亚这种高度竞争性的社会。
她都非常能理解，因为她早已经在很多的韩剧。
台湾电影啊，大陆电影里面看过了。
所以我们之间的沟通。
我觉得她真的是付出了非常非常多的爱，理解和包容的。
去这样看见一个来自中国的年轻的女孩。
包括奶奶也跟我分享过很多她跟中国房客的故事。
我印象特别深的就是她说。
疫情期间有一个之前来住过的在武汉的女孩。
在意大利疫情最严重的时候。
我给她们寄过来一整箱的口罩。
让她们除了自己用，还可以发给周围的邻居使用。
我还记得我当时听到这些的时候。
觉得，哇，这真的是一种很让人感动的途径。
就好像地球村这个词，还没有消失一样。
人和人之间跨越着这么遥远的距离。
你还能想到之前你在她家里住过的这位老人。
然后又用这么多的心意和实际的行动。
寄过来一大箱的口罩。
我想，这可能就是世界给我们的礼物吧？
她可能会给你一个崴脚。
给你无数次的搬家。
但也会让你在搬迁的过程中遇到这样的一些人。
就像是Francesca和她那个挂满女性肖像的家。
还有Kala奶奶，这样一个民间美食家。
特别喜欢看韩剧
也特别关注东亚年轻人的精神状态。
在那几个月的相处里。
我有时候真的会觉得。
他们好像就是我在意大利的妈妈和奶奶。
但在这个过程中
你可能也会遇到很drama的一些人和事。
比如我之前租过一个留学生的短租房。
她当时租给我一个房间。
但她跟我说她要回国了。
所以那期间可能那个房子里面只会有我一个人。
但是我在第一天我就发现了有猫猫。
但她没有跟我说有猫，我就很疑惑。
结果住了三天
我发现家里不知道从哪个角落竄出来一只猫。
然后一周之后
我总有把就带着她那条狗回来家里面住。
而且那条狗是一只铃铁。
铃铁是那种腿很长的赛极拳嘛？
它其实每天需要非常大的运动量。
但这些它都没有告诉我。
然后惊喜的事情来了。
我每天早上起床的时候。
如果睡眼心松没有注意看的话。
一不小心就会踩到厕所正中央的狗室。
因为那只狗每天早上都会在厕所里面拉屎。
而且它尿尿的地方就是我们领域的地方。
不好意思，希望没有朋友现在正在吃饭。
我觉得那是我人生中非常荒谬。
但是有非常真实的一段记忆呀？
你想想一下
在文艺附近的遥览佛罗伦萨这个小镇里面。
我每天早起的第一件事。
就是睡眼心松的躲避厕所里的狗室。
这其实特别能反映意大利这个国家人们的生存处境。
你想到意大利的第一件事。
可能是美好的阳光，沙滩，海边。
还有Combino Nam那样的夏日时光。
但生存在这里你就会发现。
每天是吃不完的Salami和Pasta。
是非常低的薪水，非常高的房租。
是身边那些30岁了还得和父母集在一起住的年轻人。
你会发现，在这里旅游跟在这里生活。
是完全不同的两把势。
所以我住在那里那段时间真的要崩溃了。
因为每天起床就要面对各种屎尿屁的事情。
但是当我跟他沟通这件事的时候。
他态度非常糟糕
然后直接就说
那下周你就直接搬走吧？
因为当时我们没有签合同。
我的钱也确实只交到了那周。
所以我就被迫无奈的又开始搬家。
我还记得那时候大概是9月还是10月吧？
我去到佛罗伦萨大概有快一年了。
我都没有哭过
但那一天我不知道为什么就是很难忍住我的眼泪。
我觉得那可能是我第一次体会到。
加这个东西可以变得如此之沉重。
好像当时我在青麦体会到的那种一个行李箱。
就可以拖起整个人生的自由。
在佛罗伦萨那一年被一点一点的打碎。
那时候我看着那两个行李箱。
我体会到的是一种很重很重的感觉。
它变成了一种非常沉重的负担。
因为我经常不知道自己下一站要住在哪里。
我的行李放在哪里。
下一周要睡在哪里。
我忽然意识到说
人不是只靠轻盈活着的。
人也需要安稳
需要一个地方能够沉脱住你。
能够让你的心力不是每天花在找房租房。
和这些踩到狗室
或是打碎房东的登站的事情。
而这种胶着会直接影响到你的工作。
你的创作
你根本没有心力去想要创作什么？
你每天只会被这种生存的焦虑所困扰。
甚至我可以跟大家说。
我当时在国内的时候。
是个非常坚定的不买房主义者。
因为我当时觉得买房。
都是给自己的生命上的枷锁。
你会完全失去自由。
剩下的就是每个月都要缴房大的负担。
但是在佛罗伦萨不断失去家。
不断搬家的那一年。
我人生中第一次产生了想要买个房子的冲动。
其实那不是因为我有钱了。
而是因为我觉得在肉身极度。
缺乏安全感的时候。
你会产生一种很原始的本能。
我渴望重力
渴望那种一个家
一个安稳的空间
能够把我拖住的感觉。
所以也是在那个时候。
我突然能理解
为什么身边的很多朋友。
会想要买房
会想要一个家
也是在那段时间吧？
我再次去看那些像。
美食祈祷恋爱
或者托斯坎那艳阳下这样的电影。
我都有了截然不同的感受。
之前你会觉得
哦 放弃自己原本的身份和生活。
去到一个语言完全不同的国家。
世界很美妙的事情。
因为一切都可以从头来过。
你的人生好像会有崭新的方向。
我觉得滴滴确确有这样的感受。
但这些租房 房子漏水。
遇到奇葩的室友
或是每天要在邮局。
跟大爷大妈扯皮的这些过程。
在电影里面
可能就占据了不到五分之一的时间。
但现实里面
这些事情其实很像一根根小小的针。
它会不断的秘密麻麻地刺向你。
你会总是被这样的焦灼和忧虑包围着。
然后当你发现的时候。
你会意识到自己的身上。
已经有很多隐秘的伤口了。
而这种隐痛的感觉。
可能就是漂泊
也是在那个流水生通知。
我不能在住的那个下午。
我收到了奶奶的邮件。
对
我们每次联系
其实都还是通过邮件。
然后奶奶就问我说。
你最近在这边怎么样。
找到房子了吗？
现在住在哪里
然后她说
如果你找不到房子。
你就随时来奶奶这里住。
你要知道
你在佛罗伦萨永远有一个家。
那是一个家
你要知道
你在佛罗伦萨永远有一个家。
然后我当时看到这里的时候。
我心里就白感焦急。
而且很神奇的
那天也同时收到了。
Franchesca的Whatsapp的消息。
她也跟我说了差不多的话。
她说她最近
正在经历一段很艰难的时期。
但她总会想到那个下雨天。
我托着三个行李箱走进她的家。
然后两个灵魂就这么相遇了。
她觉得是一件很美妙的事情。
有时候她会感谢佛罗伦萨这么小。
是因为这样
我们才能在这里相遇。
所以每当我说几次在佛罗伦萨这一年。
我经常会觉得
我是很倒霉的
但是我又是很幸运的。
我可以在这一年里。
同时经历了外交
三个月不能走路
到斑巴自家
然后再遇到了非常多奇葩的。
可能在这个波克里将一将不完的。
糟糕的事情
但是我又可以遇到。
像当时帮助我来佛罗伦萨的朋友。
Francesca。
还有卡拉奶奶
这样的人
我记得之前跟我朋友说到。
这些经历的话
她说
这些如果是你
我可能真的没有勇气过去。
或者说
她在听了我这些经历之后。
会对要不要出来
这件事情变得更犹豫了。
因为她知道有多辛苦。
可能会遭遇多少糟糕的事情。
但是我当时脑子里闪过的一个念头是。
如果我没有来
我就不会遇到这些人了呀？
我就不会有这么多神奇的经历。
无论他是糟糕的
好的 坏的
他们都是一些
可能只会发生在我这个人生上的事情。
我多了比别人这么多的体验。
而这些东西
她有可能都可以化作过。
以后人生中的
说个很土的词
财富
或者是变成创作的养料。
所以
那就去体验吧？
人生是没有回头路的。
也只有当你真的经历之后。
你才会发现
就是这些东西塑造了你呀？
也差不多是花了一年的时间吧？
我就已经知道
我没有办法在佛罗伦萨继续待下去了。
不只是租房吧？
我也发现了
其实我并没有那么的适应小镇生活。
可能很多人都思考过这样一个问题啊？
你是更喜欢在小镇过安稳无忧的生活呢？
还是去大城市闯荡。
过过更精彩
但也更高风险的人生呢？
在我人生前面的阶段。
甚至在我出国之前。
我可能都会觉得我喜欢小镇。
我来到大城市只是迫不得已。
但我真的在这个小镇住了一年之后。
我就发现
原来小镇的这种安逸和宁静。
也意味着
它其实每天的无事发生。
你可能在这里生活60年。
你身边的人
还是同小陪你长大那些人。
但我发现
这个阶段的我
其实充满了探索世界的好奇心。
我希望感知到更多的东西。
我希望接触到各式各样的有趣的人。
所以可能这就注定了。
我没有办法在这个小镇里面。
长久的呆下去
而且意大利这种国度。
它不像我们国内
各方面都电子化非常的便捷。
你住在小镇和大城市的。
体感差异是非常大的。
打个比方
来到意大利之后
你首先要获取在这里的居住许可。
也就是我们所谓的拘留卡。
像在国内
你可能只需要在网上申请就好。
包括我问了很多在法国巴黎的朋友。
他们现在也是网络申请。
但在意大利
会有一种非常古老的方式。
是你首先要去到邮局。
对
邮局也是个
听起来非常古老的词汇。
你要去那里的窗口排队。
然后取一个大信封。
里面就会有很多
你需要填好的信息。
然后你把你自事学生。
你来自哪里
各方面信息都填好之后。
你又要回到邮局
然后去排队
等待他们给你寄出那个信封。
在寄出的时候
他们就会告诉你
你哪年哪一天
就可以去按手印
然后在这个过程中。
你就需要准备
非常多的文件资料。
就光说他们给你
预约那个按手印的时间。
我当时是23年的12月去的。
你们知道给我排到什么时候吗？
25年的7月
我当时都惊呆了
我想说那这整整
一年多的时间里面。
我岂不是签证过期之后。
我身份就黑了
他们说对
但是没有办法
他们会给你一个拘留小条。
但是那个小条
其实没有任何的用处。
你哪个欧盟国家都不能去。
你要么待在意大利。
要么回国
所以你看这么一件小事。
就能从侧面反映出。
整个意大利的效率。
是非常非常拉垮的。
然后在佛罗伦萨中小镇。
他有期
所以我当时才会选择米兰。
因为在米兰
你预约按手印的时间。
只需要三个月
如果是我年轻的时候。
可能会觉得
哇 这多美景啊？
你因为一些很现实的原因。
而选择你住在哪里。
这真的很不浪漫
但当你体会到
这些现实的重力之后。
你会发现
所有的这些琐瑟的事情。
它都会成为消磨你的关键。
而当人长期处在一种。
被消磨的
被耗尽的状态之中。
它其实是没有真正意上的自由的。
很多人可能会问我说。
那你为什么不回国啊？
我觉得原因很简单吧？
就是我还没有甘心。
因为我在佛罗伦萨。
这一年没有真正的住下来过。
我几乎总是处在一种。
打包或者准备打包的状态。
所以我对意大利这个国家。
对于欧洲这个大陆。
其实都还没有真正的认识。
而体验和感受
就是我想来到欧洲的目的吗？
有一些朋友可能也会问我说。
你为什么不去罗马。
罗马也很好啊？
但说实话
在佛罗伦萨这年的折腾。
我已经对那种
美的像电影一样的城市。
产生了PTSD
而且就我知道了
罗马的效率可能
比佛罗伦萨还要可怕。
而且更加混乱
我意识到我现阶段的状态。
我想要探索和体验。
更大世界的这种心态。
更需要的其实是一个。
能让我的生活正常运转的城市。
其实米兰对意大利人来说。
也是一个有点异类的城市。
我当时说我要去米兰的时候。
我身边那些在
佛罗伦萨和罗马朋友。
都是一脸惊讶
说啊为什么要去那个城市啊？
连意大利人最多会吐槽米兰。
说他太阴冷
说他灰不扑的
然后整个街上都很脏。
全是狗屎
就很不像意大利
但对那个阶段的我来说。
这些缺点都已经像是优点了。
我不需要一个浪漫的城市。
因为他已经坑了我太多次了。
我就需要一个正常的。
甚至没有那么美好的城市。
但在米兰找房
又是一种我之前
完全没有体验过的经历。
因为那时候我已经。
从语言学校毕业了。
而因为换城市
还有我觉得佛罗伦萨的。
种古典的非常传统的教学方式。
我并不喜欢
所以我没有把那个学业继续下去。
我这样一个自由职业者。
在房东眼里
就是一个没有稳定收入的外国人。
找房的难度是非常高的。
我到现在都记得
我给房东准备了整整六页的PDF。
上面详细介绍了我是谁。
我来自哪里
我为什么要来意大利。
这些年我做的工作。
我的收入证名
号推荐信
自我介绍等等
那个瞬间我都想说。
我这是在找房吗？
我感觉好像是在求职。
而且我记得
当时我让Francesca和奶奶。
当我的担保人
而房东真的打电话过去问了。
而且每个人都打了半小时左右。
而你知道那个决定性因素是什么吗？
是房东跟Francesca聊得很开心。
然后发现
我房东的月母居然就住在。
Francesca家的附近。
然后他觉得很开心。
很有保障
你看
意大利其实有很多跟中国。
非常相似的地方
它是一个非常非常吃人情。
关系网络的社会
在这里
如果你没有建立几次的关系网。
可能很多路都是独死的。
但除了这个
一个很关键的要素是。
我一次性交了3个月的押金。
和半年的房租
因为如果不这样
你比起其他收入
稳定的意大利当地人。
你是没有任何的优势的。
所以在外面租房
我觉得很多人都是吃尽了苦头。
但经过两个多月的折腾。
我终于找到了现在住的这个房子。
我还记得在之前的视频。
我跟大家分享过
我特别喜欢Francesca家。
我的那个房间里正中间的那个桌子。
那是一个木头的桌子。
然后有一个很漂亮的小台灯。
我真的一走进去
看到那个桌子
我就觉得
这个就是我的空间。
我一定能够在这里写出。
很多的东西
而后来我真的就在那里。
创作出了几个我非常喜欢的视频。
后来大家很熟悉的。
电影美学和女性创作的第一期视频。
都是在这个房间
这张桌子上创作出来的。
每次我呆在这里
就会觉得能量特别的高。
说到这里我发现
好像每一个我很喜欢的空间。
都有个特点
就是有一张让我特别喜欢的。
在这里写作和创作。
会很舒服的书桌
我记得我第一次走进来的时候。
真的很满意
因为你要知道在米兰。
找到一个各方面格局很周正。
采光很好
甚至有一个小羊
他的房就多不容易。
而且我最喜欢的部分。
是卧室的对面
就是一颗松树
而且当时这个卧室是没有书桌的。
在客厅中央有一张桌子。
它又可以当餐桌
又可以当工作桌
我其实只需要在那里工作就好了。
但我还是自己又去一家。
买了一张白色的书桌。
放在这个窗户面前。
让我每次在这里看书。
或者写东西的时候。
就可以看到这个松树。
我现在录音的时候。
眼前看着的就是这个松树。
我当时看到这棵树。
看到这个卧室的瞬间。
我就想
这就是我要的房子。
这就是我要在米兰扎根的地方。
我还记得那天我找了一个。
华人的司机
然后我把我所有的东西。
三个行李箱
加上在佛罗伦萨那一年。
积攒的一些小的东西。
两个袋子吧？
一起放进了他车的后备箱。
然后我告别了奶奶和他的家人。
一路从佛罗伦萨开到米兰。
你会发现那个天变得越来越阴。
天气越来越糟糕
我终于进入到了
这个被意大利人称之为。
灰扑扑的阴暗的城市。
但是我当时好开心啊？
我把行李箱放在客厅里面打开。
你们知道那种感觉吗？
当你过去一年都在搬家。
行李箱永远是关上又河龙。
又随时要打开的状态。
但这个时候
你终于可以把它打开铺屏。
把所有的东西一件一件拿出来。
挂进衣柜放进抽屉里面。
我当时真的以为
我漂泊的人生终于要。
阶段性的结束了
我终于可以好好的安静的。
在一个我想住的地方住下来了。
直到我在这间房子。
醒来的第一天早上。
我听到了那个声音。
那是墙壁里面暖气管道碰撞。
传出来的声音
我当时找了很多的师傅。
其实无外乎是几种情况。
一种是管道热脏冷缩之后。
碰撞在一起的声音。
另外一种是管道里面。
可能存在空气
它在管道里面乱串的声音。
无论哪种原因
在国内可能是花一周。
甚至一个月就能解决的事情。
但我不知道
这会成为我后面四个月的噩梦。
关于怎么解决这个暖气管噪音的事情。
我都觉得我可以单开一期波克来讲了。
因为实在是太波折了。
但总之就是
它敲开了我卧室的墙。
然后又敲开了我楼上的墙。
又敲开了我楼下的墙。
最后一整栋楼的墙都被敲碎了。
但还是花了整整三个月。
换了好几个师工队。
才终于找到了问题。
而在这个过程中
我的工作和生活都很难正常地展开。
所以我被迫要回去国内住两个月。
但在这过程中
我跟房东交涉
我还是必须得正常的付我的房租。
而它给我的赔偿就是。
它在伊斯卡一个小岛上面。
有一个度假房子
我可以免费地去那边住。
除此之外没有任何的赔偿。
那段时间我印象最深刻的就是。
在意大利经常会发生一个对话。
什么意思
该怎么办呢？
不知道啊？
包括在意大利语里面。
有一句话叫
大概意思就是
谁知道呢？
下水倒毒了
火车晚点啊？
房子漏水
我觉得这种态度有它可爱的地方。
它会让生活变得不那么紧繃。
让人有空间变得慢吞吞的。
去喝咖啡去聊天去晒太阳。
这也是很多人
包括我
为什么会喜欢意大利。
但当你是个需要住在这里生活。
工作
解决很多具体问题的人。
你就会发现
中基斯是一面双人间。
它的情引是建立在很多事情。
根本就不会被解决前提下的。
那时候我才意识到。
我之前对意大利的喜欢。
是一种游客式的喜欢。
游客当然是可以享受中基斯啊？
因为反正一周之后。
这些问题就跟你没关系了。
也是那个时候我意识到。
原来世界上不存在一个完美的城市。
你不能够一方面喜欢这个城市的古老。
和它的散漫
但是一方面你又要求它效率高。
或者更新快
而当然这个管道噪音。
只是一系列事情的开端。
在米兰这一年
我做了很多的努力去适应它。
我学意大利语
试图追求很多朋友。
有华人朋友
也有本地的朋友
努力去理解和适应这种意大利的文化。
但在这一年里
我有一个很强力的感觉。
我好像在一个看似完美的房子里面。
又觉得自己被困住了。
那是一种很难描述的感觉。
我会觉得
如果用一个词去形容。
我在每个城市的感受。
我觉得在青麦那一年我是轻盈的。
在佛罗伦萨那一年。
我可能是狼狈的
但狼狈也是一种很强力的生命感受。
你会觉得你是被那座城市激活的。
但在米兰的时候
我又有一种说不出来的。
收缩的感觉
我觉得我整个人好像是被收紧的。
就即使你每天是照常的工作生活。
去超市买菜
你维持这种正常体面的活法。
但每天走在街上
我总有一种很莫名的。
我跟这个城市之间。
隔着一层膜的那种感觉。
我不知道大家会不会也有这种感受啊？
说实话
我好像很难去命名。
或者去解释这种状态。
它跟佛罗伦萨的感觉又不一样。
虽然在佛罗伦萨很狼狈。
也遇到很多倒霉的事情。
但你知道这个城市跟你有关。
但在米兰会有一种。
好像在这个弱大的城市里面。
我只是一个漂浮的小州。
而我跟周遭的一切的关联。
都不是那么强烈的感觉。
这是一个很适合工作的城市。
我在这里完成了很多个视频。
我每天能够竟然有序的过我的生活。
但我好像没有一种被滋养的感觉。
生活好像就处在了一种玄空的状态。
因为虽然在佛罗伦萨也是这样。
但那时候我在读语言学校。
我每天要去上课
会跟班里的同学、老师。
甚至周边的小店都有接触。
这种学业的忙碌
再加上你刚去的新鲜感。
会让你有一种非常非常充沛的感受。
但是当我在米兰
我作为一个自由职业者。
我不需要去学校跟人接触。
我也不需要上班
甚至我跟当地人的接触。
也可能就是在周边喝个咖啡的关系。
这就导致你很难融入当地。
你始终有一种玄空的感觉。
但与此同时
你好像又非常自由。
自由到净乎一种真空的状态。
那时候我忽然想到了一部电影。
叫《蓝》
是杰斯洛夫斯基的红白蓝三部曲例的《蓝》
他讲的是一个女人。
因为一场意外的车祸。
失去了她的丈夫和孩子。
所以他忽然就变成了一个自由又富有的人。
虽然很悲痛
但这也是一种非常自由的状态。
但我还记得这部电影。
其中一个修复版的《海豹》
是一只旋载半空中的风筝。
什么意思呢？
就是当你处在一种极致的自由中时。
你处在了一种极致的真空和玄空的状态中。
那是一种没有中立去约束你的状态。
却意味着
你好像没有了那种毛点和支点。
可以让你在这个生活中。
体验到一些切切实实的情感和现实的中立。
虽然在这个期间
我也很努力的去尝试了。
但是中有一种
我好像不属于这个城市。
这个城市也不属于我的感觉。
在这个过程中
我也很多次的对我自己说。
你好像真的很矫情。
现在你也没有那么多倒霉的事情。
暖气也修好了
为什么就不能好好的踏踏实实。
在这个城市里面
像大多数人一样生活下去呢？
但那种理性上
明明一切好像都没有问题。
但感性上
你就是觉得无法融入。
和很难喜欢的感觉。
一直维持了很久
在米兰的这一年
我意识到了一件事情。
其实一张完美的桌子。
和一个很好的家是不够的。
一个空间它再好
如果周围的世界不能够滋养你。
那那个空间最终也会变得越来越小。
会变成一个困住你的东西。
而后来我决定要离开米兰的契机。
是再一段我觉得有点被困住的时间。
我临时起买了一张。
火车票
坐了七个小时的火车。
从米兰去到了巴黎。
当时我只是想去巴黎玩几天。
偷偷气
但那次去巴黎
我遇到了我在巴黎的房东。
Dennis和Adine。
他们是我当时在巴黎住的那几天的。
LBNB的房东
很神奇的
他们是一对大概六七十岁的夫妇。
Dennis是一个来自南非的作家。
Adine是一个来自美国的摄影师。
他们40年前在巴黎相遇。
然后一起生活到了现在。
我还记得那天我走进他们的家。
是在一栋奥斯曼建筑里。
但他们其实并不是旁边的那些公寓。
而是在一个大门打开进去之后。
你会发现有一个小小的花园。
然后他们的房子就是一个玻璃房子。
被那些花和草包围。
而那些花草都是他们自己栽种的。
走进去的那一刻
我忽然有种很熟悉的感觉。
就像是我走进奶奶或者Franchesca家。
我后来回想
我觉得这种熟悉的感觉。
可能是我们的身体和我们的经验。
在替我们做选择
他就在告诉你说
这个地方是对的
那天我刚下火车还没来得及吃午饭。
Adine就邀请我过来这张桌子。
一起吃午餐
我们就坐在他们家那张很大的。
木头桌子面前
开始吃饭 开始聊天。
他们问了我很多问题。
为什么会来到欧洲。
为什么会住在米兰。
在那边的感受怎么样。
然后我在巴黎的那五天四夜。
每次我从外面回来。
回到这张桌子前面。
我们就会一直聊天。
很奇怪的
我跟这两个六七十岁的老人。
也有一种一件如故的感觉。
我想可能大概因为。
我遇到的这些人
都是特别特别好的人吧？
而我身上的这种好奇。
这种向外敞开的能量。
或许也让他们感知到。
这个年轻人
真的对世界有很多的好奇。
也对他们的生活有很多的好奇。
我觉得有一天
就只有我和Dennis。
然后这位老先生就问我说。
你喜欢米兰吗？
那一刻我有点不知道。
应该怎么回答
我就想了一下说
好像理性上
一切都是很合适的。
但我就是没有一种。
在这个城市里面
我舒展开了的感觉。
好像走在街上的
每个人都很时尚
但是大家也都有点冷漠。
然后我就随口说
我可能还是想
继续搬到另一个城市吧？
我不知道
可能是巴黎
其实在那个时候
我根本就没有下定决心。
我就是随口说了一句。
但就是在那一刻
Dennis突然跟我说了一句话。
他说
好了
我现在要停止我们的对话。
我要把你从这个房子里面。
赶出去
因为时间在流逝
你必须要走出去
去感受巴黎
去感受这里的这一切。
然后你才会知道
要不要搬到这里
这里是不是适合你。
说实话
我其实已经不是
第一次说这件事情了。
但我现在讲起来
都会有一种
起鸡皮疙瘩的感觉。
因为在那一刻
我意识到
这好像是我在米兰。
整整一年
都没有遇到过的事情。
他说这个话是在催促我。
但我觉得他不是在催促我。
做决定
而是在催我去感受。
感受这个城市里的一切。
人和事
然后你才知道
是不是合你
我觉得好像是因为。
佛罗伦萨那段经历。
让我有了一种
非常理性的物质的感受。
觉得我应该选择
一个对的城市
但我好像忘记了
自己的感受
或者说那种感受
是更质厚的
但有的时候
真正帮我们做决定的。
可能不只是理性上。
那些对的东西
也是感性上的
这种身体的感受
我觉得Dennis那段话。
让我觉得非常触动。
是因为他在告诉我。
不要忘记你的感受。
而非常奇妙的
我觉得在巴黎那几天。
好像所有我在米兰。
觉得很艰难的事情。
都意外的变得很简单。
比如交朋友
虽然后来
我也在这里结实了一些。
很好的华人的朋友。
但因为大家住的比较远。
所以每次见面
都还是比较难的
我就还是需要去打开一下。
我在这边的交集的圈子。
但我发现好像
每次我都需要
非常努力的
铺使自己跟别人对话。
然后看一下
有没有变成朋友的可能。
这对我来说
真的是一件
非常非常难的事情。
因为我
不是那种非常外向的人。
但在巴黎那几天
我就发现
好像我并没有刻意的。
去跟别人说话
但好像就会因为
一些莫名其妙的原因。
解释到新的朋友
有法国人
有中国人
有在法国留学的外国人。
包括会有很多咖啡店。
我一看到
我就很想进去
在包括巴黎
有非常多的
和电影相关的空间。
MK2的电影院
还有像Cinematic。
这样的电影资料馆。
每一个空间
都会让我流连忘返。
觉得可以在那里
戴上一整天
我甚至认识了
两位在巴黎
开中文书店的朋友。
我还记得那个下雨天。
然后去到他们店里面。
我们聊得很开心
有一种
虽然是第一次见面。
但是老有相见的感觉。
我就觉得他们
当时跟我说
今天天气不好
如果天气好的话
你可以去旁边走走。
因为旁边就是猴脉。
和瓦尔达的墓
瓦尔达当时就住在这附近。
你们知道吗？
我当时在听到那句话的时候。
有一种
好像这个对话发生过的感觉。
法语里面不是有句话吗？
叫Deja Vu。
我觉得好像
就是那种熟悉的感觉。
因为一切都是你喜欢的。
你热爱的人和事
当他们在这一刻
和你的生命经验
相连在一起的时候。
就是所谓的熟悉的感觉。
因为这个国度
就是产生了那些
你最喜欢的导演
作家 画家
而好像巴黎这个地方。
就是有一种奇妙的磁场。
它会让那些搞艺术。
创作的人
最后都会集到这个地方来。
而一个城市是什么样的。
它就会吸引什么样的人过来。
而你在这个空间
也大概能够遇到
跟你频率很相近的人。
所以我觉得
这或许不是幻觉吧？
而是一种
经验
我觉得好像正是在这种感受里面。
我那种对米兰说不清。
道不明的
并没有那么融入的感觉。
一切都有了解释
我还记得有一天
我经过一个甜品店。
买了一个马卡龙
这个是我小时候一直很想吃。
但是没有吃到过的马卡龙。
我咬了一口
我发现是一种甜甜的。
但又不那么粘膩的感觉。
我忽然想起小时候。
我问过一个
做高点的姐姐个问题。
我当时问她
姐姐你怎么知道一个东西好不好吃。
高质量的马卡龙
是一种什么样的口味啊？
她当时回了我一句话。
我记到现在
她说
你吃的好吃的
就知道什么是好的力啊？
而当时我站在巴黎的街头。
看着手中的马卡龙。
我忽然明白了一件事。
我不再纠结于
我为什么对米兰没有感觉了。
因为当我来到巴黎。
当我知道什么是对的感觉后。
那些所有为什么不对的感觉。
就突然有了解释
你不需要再去分析。
但与此同时
我也有一种害怕的感觉。
就是那种你在一个地方待了几天。
你会有一种
哇这里好棒
我想留在那里的感觉。
但那很可能
只是因为你是游客。
那是一种短暂的幻觉。
就像我一开始
对付了伦萨的滤镜一样。
所以那次回到米兰之后。
我思考了很久
这究竟是不是一种幻觉。
而为了搞清楚这件事。
我后来又去了第二次。
第三次巴黎
我并不是一种抱着去玩的心态。
其实那些最著名的。
卢福公开学门
我当时都没有去
我只是用一种
我想真切的在这里生活一段时间。
看这里究竟是不是适合我的地方。
的那种感受
去在巴黎住一段时间。
甚至在我第二次去巴黎的时候。
我发了个帖子
去约了很多在巴黎生活的。
中国的女生
我跟她们一个个的聊天。
问她们在巴黎的
一种真实的生活状态。
然后对比我在意大利。
这边所有的感受
从多长时间可以拿到拘留卡。
到在这边租房难不难。
再到整个法国的行政系统。
和基础设施等等
我做了很多很多
资料的搜集和功课。
我后来觉得
我对巴黎的这种好感。
应该不是幻觉
其实调查下来
巴黎并不是完美的。
它很贵
它办事也挺慢的
虽然肯定是比意大利快的。
然后签证所有的这些问题。
都很难搞
但即使知道了这些。
我也并没有动摇
我知道搬去巴黎
要面对太多太多的阻碍。
甚至比我一开始来到意大利。
还要难
然后在这个过程中。
我会不断的想到
Dennis跟我说的那句话。
你要走出去
你要去感受
我觉得这句话
可能不只是关于巴黎的吧？
我忽然觉得这几年。
我所有的搬家
我所有的折腾
那些我的父母并不理解。
但是我还是想去做的决定。
都是在做他说的那件事。
去感受
我还记得我妈总会跟我说。
她说
这是潮汕话
翻译过来就是
孩子你为什么总是要到处跑呢？
你不能就在一个地方安稳的。
逮下来吗？
她甚至用一个词来形容我。
洗心验救
她说你没发现你就是。
在一个地方
待了几年之后就受不了。
然后又要去其他的地方吗？
这样子你的人生哪里是镜头呢？
说实话
她当时跟我说
这句话的时候
我是有一点被触动到的。
我在想
我真的是这样子的人吗？
但与此同时
我又想相信我的感受。
而且我觉得她也不只是感受。
她有这几年
我非常多的经验
和理性的思考判断在里面。
所以我还蛮想尝试一下。
那么下一站
如果我真的去了巴黎。
我是否会对这些事情。
有着新的思考和变化。
就在前几天
我在我的小红书上面。
发了一个帖子
跟大家说
我很有可能下半年。
会搬到巴黎去了
我记得当时
下面有一条评论
让我非常有感触
她说
切切好有执行力
如果我出国来到一个新的地方。
无论怎样
我可能都会接受了。
毕竟离开
还要学习新的语言。
但切切可以再尝试了意大利之后。
最终希望决定在巴黎生活。
带给我小小的震撼。
原来
还可以继续离开
继续有新的选择
而我当时是这么回答她的。
我说
可能是因为我对自己。
不喜欢的东西
忍受的预知
真的非常低吧？
其实这也会带来很多的痛苦。
折腾
甚至弯路
等我以后有机会在播客里面。
也可以慢慢的展开。
跟大家分享
但这个女孩子
她回复了我这样一句话。
她说
我应该是你的另一面。
如果此时此地
让我感到痛苦
但这种痛苦
我非常熟悉
这种熟悉
让人代变得相对容易。
也让我感到安全
因为去改变的结果。
是未知的
也许
我会遇到更大的困难。
或许也会有更糟的事情。
等着我
我总是在做之前
就被乱七八糟的想法吓到。
但原来
还可以再次选
选到自己真正喜欢的。
我真的有被启发的。
而我想
这也是我想去做这些事情。
并且在这期播客里面。
跟大家分享
所有的这些
心路历程的原因吧？
如果我能做为一个小小的样本。
让大家看到
原来去折腾
也能在这个过程中。
体会到非常多
美妙的
糟糕的
独一无二的感受
并且通过这种折腾。
去接近一种
你更想要的人生
那我觉得
或许也可以给大家。
带来一双新的眼睛。
去重新看待一些东西。
然后此时此刻
我的窗外
依旧是那颗松树
我的身后
也还是那两个
摊开的行李箱
说实话
最近
我的状态并不是很好。
我想起
去年这个时候
去干那之前
我也是处于这种
冰荒马乱的状态
当时虽然我的暖气管。
已经修好了
但是在那两天的时间里面。
接连发生了
我的冰箱整个坏掉。
然后我的热水器
也坏掉的情况
所以我当时必须
每天去
超市里面买东西
因为东西不能放冰箱。
很快就会坏
五月了
我的热水器
已经开始有点热了。
然后我要
每天去烧水
然后洗澡的时候
就只能用
烧开来的这些水
给自己
一点一点的浇下去。
就像浇花一样
而且我当时的手机。
还坏了
但是我的牙马訊
用不了
因为我的卡被备了。
所以我就
还很紧急的
买了个新手机
一切都是乱糟糟的。
好像就不会
好起来了一样
但就在去干那的
前一天
我的新的冰箱
送过来了
我的热水器修好了。
我的新手机
也买到了
在我坐着列车
去干那的那一刻
我心想
原来人生的节点
不是那一个
那么大的事件
它可能真的就是
有这么一些
微小的事情
构成的
而你也是
在无数的这样
细碎的时刻里面
把自己
一点点重建起来
像浇花一样
一点点的
去灌溉自己
而两天之后
我就要去干那了
而我也开始
有点期待
今年的干那
会发生什么呢？
希望有机会的话
能在波克里面
跟大家分享
我在干那的经历
也欢迎大家
在评论区
分享你的故事
和思考
也告诉我们说
你还想在
这档波克里面
听到哪些内容
也可以写信
通过邮箱告诉我们。
邮箱地址
也会放在
这期节目的
那么？
这期波克
就到此为止啦
我们下一次见
希望到时候
就有新的故事了
拜拜
我们下一次见
优优独播出